acting Attorney General Matthew Whitaker
told Congress he has not interfered with
Special Counsel Robert Muller's Russia
investigation of the 2016 presidential
election it often the combative
testimony on Friday
Democrats grilled Whitaker about any
conversations he had with President
Trump Steve Dorsey is at the White House
Steve what can you tell us well good
morning the Trump administration got its
first glimpse of what life will be like
now that Democrats control the house
with acting Attorney General Matthew
Whitaker facing six hours of scrutiny by
Democrats on the Judiciary Committee
prompting some tense exchanges do you
swear affirm under penalty of perjury
from the beginning the country's top law
enforcement official made it clear he
was not there to answer tough questions
from Democratic lawmakers wanting to get
to the bottom of his role in the Moller
probe now in your capacity as acting
Attorney General have you ever been
asked to approve any requests or action
to be taken by the special counsel mr.
Chairman I see that your five minutes is
up and so Whitaker denied interfering in
the investigation but refused to answer
most questions about it as you know I
cannot talk about ongoing investigation
I'm not going to characterize that
investigation congressman I'm not a
puppet to repeat what you're saying
frustrated Democrats tried
unsuccessfully to pin down Whitaker this
is my time mr. Whitaker you don't run
this committee Republicans accuse
Democrats of a dog and pony show we're
gonna have plenty of theatrics bring
your popcorn I'm thinking about maybe we
just set up a popcorn machine in the
back because that's what this is
becoming Whitaker replaced fired
Attorney General Jeff Sessions in
November president Trump long criticized
sessions for recusing himself from the
Russia probe Whitaker rejected advice
from justice officials to do the same
isn't it a fact that career officials at
DOJ recommend it to you that you recuse
yourself it was my decision to make I
decided not to recuse before his
appointment Whitaker had been an
outspoken critic of the Malheur probe
which many Democrats believe was the
reason
to Trump picked him do you still believe
that the Muller investigation is a lynch
mob congressman can you tell me
specifically where I said that on August
6th of 2017 you made reference to a note
to Trump's lawyer do not cooperate with
Muller's lynch mob i recall that i said
that i retweeted an article that was
that was titled that i did not
necessarily agree with this that the
Senate is expected to confirm Whitaker's
permanent replacement William bar soon
meanwhile the president hasn't weighed
in on Whitaker's hearing he spent much
of the day at a Walter Reed Medical
Center for his annual physical where
doctors deemed him in very good health
Anthony Steve thanks